voir les enfants
j'espère que vous avez passé une bonne
journée
alors nounours tu ne descend pas voir
tes amis
coucou nounours aquarev thuau
excusez-moi patron je respire le parfum
du printemps les senteurs deux heures
off le sais tu que nous sommes arrivés
au dessus de chez nicolas et pimprenelle
se ferait au vite mon le seul os le
printemps
l'offre
comprend pas pourquoi
et voilà papa maman m'ont dit tu peux
rester trois jours et on viendra te
chercher au roman vient peut-être venir
du musée et puis ces jantes et d'avoir
amené juliette d'un beau soir ou encore
niche au col surprise
salut nous nous
vient enfin juliette pas elle a reconnu
les maisons tout seuls
bonsoir je
bats veulent
la porter au marbre le temps flore c'est
magnifique
oh ce que ça sent bon le printemps et
cornichons il a apporté
bien voilà qu'elle devra pour toi nous
j'ai cueilli dans ma forme me reçut
cordes et son
rôle parfait regarde il ya aussi des
violets touchez pas aux violets pourquoi
j'ai une surprise
demain matin pour votre petit déjeuner
vous mangerez des tartines ou violet
tortue non violent c'est excellent tu
être un fin connaisseur hors du show
j'ai bien envie de venir prendre mon
petit déjeuner avec vous demain matin
mais à présent il est l'heure de dormir
allons au lit les enfants ou et y
installer tall un jour un élève est
l'étoile la que tu vas prendre froid tu
as en porte encore une couverture merci
nous allons nous coucher bonne nuit les
petits bobos de nuit
le pôle n'ai pas peur si je me l'état
tu veux aller promener avec nous nous
imaginions
oui elle va bien j'ai bien en route je
ne devais pas à demain les enfants
dorment une belle mine le bénin
[Musique]
mais que fait-on nounours s'il tarde
encore je vais partir sans lui
[Musique]
attendez moi j'arrive enfin n'est que tu
fais je suis allé promener juliette
temps et puis je les ramener chez
nicolas et pimprenelle
cornichons est arrivé pas trop tu me
raconteras ça en route nounours bonne
nuit les enfants au 7 juillet à adobe
[Musique]
oh
on